hey youtubers it's Charlie in my Walking
Dead finale video I asked you to submit
all of your WTF questions about the
episode in season 5 so I picked 10 of
them to answer in this video with one
bonus question I also have a few gift
cards to give away but real quick shout
out I go into detail a lot of things
that influence what might be happening
in season 5 so I go into very great
detail for that stuff during the season
5 predictions video that I'm going to be
posting later tonight time for high
fives though congratulations to Medora
beachy Boca junkie and Federico Mangano
I'll be reaching out to you on your
channels you each won a $20 Amazon gift
card don't worry if you didn't want
anything the giveaway is continuing
through Game of Thrones so there'll be
10 more weeks of the giveaway so that'll
start on Sunday with my Game of Thrones
episode 1 video so time to answer some
questions careful for potential spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet but
number 1 fells asks why is everyone in
that train car and what's up with the
shrine is that for people that the
terminus people have lost or eaten so
all very important things that a train
car obviously we thought the finale was
all about a for Alexandria but it turns
out it's really just much more for
practical reasons there was also this
crazy theory that because episode 15 was
titled us that both episodes formed this
overlapping story called USA I think
that what ended up happening is is that
on one hand you know it references that
our current predicament as in they're
stuck in train car a like it's literally
just a place but I also think that it
refers to the terminus itself remember
all those maps and Gareth even said that
all the railroad lines converge there as
in railroad line a goes to X you know X
being Alexandria in this case so maybe
it does relate to Alexandria the shrine
though has something to do with the idea
of terminus I think is a focal point
whatever their ideology is it's pretty
clear they perform human sacrifice
ending with the consumption of said
person that's what I think all those
names on the ground were for their
sacrifices who or what they're
sacrificing people to is a little
unclear right now but I think if they
were straight-up hunters then they would
just act more like Joe's group they
wouldn't take the time to write all
those creepy runes on the floor and
light candles question number two mikado
Tanaka asks why didn't Daryl tell Rick
Beth got KITT
or at the very least tell him she was
last seen driving off in a car so
Darrell is not the most forthcoming
person
he totally talks less than the grumpy
teenager or maybe he still is a grumpy
teenager either way I think he conveyed
to Rick that her status and whereabouts
are unknown you have to remember how
flawed all these people are so for every
smart thing that Rick did in this
episode someone was just as likely to do
something stupid I guess you could call
Daryl's and error of omission but he
didn't purposely withhold that it was
just like whenever Beth was trying to
question him about why he was so happy
and he just shrugged and tried to tell
her it was because she was rubbing off
on him question number three doctor who
50 and Beyond asks do you think that
Tyreese Carroll and Judith became baby
back ribs when I read your question I
actually threw up in my mouth a little
bit and then saying that Austin Powers
fat bastard song in my head no I don't
think they're dead as of the last moment
in the timeline that is I don't think
any of the survivors have been killed
that doesn't mean they won't be whenever
the season comes back though
also think about the cannibals this way
you would want the most meat you could
get per person and anyone who's a farmer
will understand why they just start with
the biggest person first and then maybe
even fatten them up a little bit more
before eating them they'd end up feeding
way more creepy psychos that way it
doesn't look like they're killing people
for pleasure just as part of some weird
ritual and for sustenance I guess that
means that Tyreese and Abraham would
probably be the first to go but we
really won't know until the first couple
of episodes question number four Calver
Thomas asks where are they in Georgia so
based on you know real life in the
terminus Maps it looks like they're in
Macon question number five bouquet
junkie asks was the whole new sheriff in
town
Beth flashback moment foreshadowing for
something I think it's foreshadowing for
Beth's character development in season
five like she's gonna be taking a new
role Robert Kirkman said that we might
not necessarily see a lot of Beth we
might not find out what's up with her
for a while that implies that she wasn't
taken to terminus and whoever grabbed
her was someone else
everyone refer back to Jesus and Gabriel
theories Emily Kinney in real life
hasn't been demoted from series regular
status so she's not off the show or
anything we will see her in episodes
just probably not as men
if everyone's at terminus right now
they'll probably spend most of the
episodes there so if she's somewhere
else we just won't see her as much her
story will happen off screen a little
bit more question number six
Cameron Peter asks could Rick or any of
them have talked their way into peace if
they come as a group no I actually don't
think it would have gone down any other
way remember that creepy shrine it said
never trust so no matter what the
terminus people would have never taken
them in and even if they did the
survivors would have flipped their [ __ ]
whenever they found out about the human
sacrifice cannibal stuff so really they
would have ended up in one of those
shipping cars no matter what question
number seven soy taylor asks during the
running scene whenever they ran past
some storage containers do you think
that was Carol Tyreese and Beth and did
anyone else notice the trash on the way
back into the train car was that
powdered milk does that mean that
they're there so actually listen to it
again it does not sound like Carol
Tyreese and obviously Judith or Beth but
I do think that they're they're the
people that were stuck in that container
sounded like someone young but not Beth
and a man but not Tyreese
I think they'll reveal those characters
in episode 1 maybe they'll be like red
shirts to the cannibals and we'll just
eat it so to speak in the first half of
the episode as an example of what's
really going on as for the powdered milk
the camera did linger on it for an
unusually long time so that means it
really is an important detail if Carol
Tyreese and Judith are at terminus I
think it's most likely they're being
kept somewhere separate you know not in
one of those containers but yes I do
feel like powdered milk equals baby so
fingers crossed that Judith is okay
question number eight cheap munch asks
do you think the Tyreese will have
something to do with their escape next
season how are they gonna escape so Rick
statement basically lets you know his
final statement that yet they're gonna
escape and they had to get to Alexandria
somehow following up on the powdered
milk theory if Tyreese isn't in a
container and they let a few people out
to sacrifice or question them they could
always buddy up and start killing other
terminus people they'd have to have at
least a couple otherwise they'd be
overwhelmed and the other terminus
people would just execute anyone left in
container a so that's actually a lot of
VIPs but here is where Morgan comes in I
know everyone wanted to see Morgan in
the finale
but he might be somewhere lurking around
terminus I do really feel like he's
going to help at some point he's
supposed to be back eventually and there
was a rumor that Scott Gimple was going
to insert him somewhere in season four
since we didn't see him in the finale
it's totally possible he could show up
in the premiere he's one of the few
crazy people with the intellect and the
resources to pull a breakout so Tyreese
+ morgan + crazy rick equals escape
question number 9 James Kirk asks what
if Beth wasn't taken by terminus and
instead by Jesus or hey soos everyone to
say it so I already mentioned you know
Jesus Gabriel theories but let me just
go a little bit further into that if
Jesus took Beth to hilltop or Alexandria
then it's likely that her story in
season 5 will just play out at one of
those locations which I actually think
is really cool it gives her an
opportunity to become more of a Carol
type badass you know hopefully she'll be
able to maintain that smile that Carol
seems to have lost but yes it is seeming
more and more likely that Beth is one
step ahead of survivors at least in
terms of you know big destinations in
the comics that the other people will
get to eventually question number 10
Oliver asks do you think the survivors
will stay terminus through season 5 so a
couple of new characters were just
bumped to series regular in season five
including Gareth so I think yes at the
very least we'll probably spend several
episodes at terminus in season five it's
just too big of a location for them to
just blow right through think of all the
sets they had to build that's a lot of
time and energy spent on something you
might just only see for two hours no
idea on which episode it'll be before
they head to Alexandria but plan on two
things an extended stay at terminus and
to learning to enjoy being a vegetarian
and one last bonus question no Sherlock
asks will there be a three-way battle in
season 5 with Rick's group vs. sanctuary
vs. Savior's so I think you're trying to
refer to the all-out war that's going on
in the comics right now no I don't think
they're gonna try and pile all those
elements into one season there will be a
ton more action but in terms of big
locations and groups we'll see I think
we'll probably only see one of the other
big locations you know either hilltop or
Alexandria and just get a peek at the
other they really do want to stretch the
story out as much as possible that means
they can hold back on the
which is like the next big a bombs that
Kirkman drops on Rick and the survivors
so thank you so much for submitting your
questions this is a ton of fun as always
I'll try to do as many q and A's as
possible in the future but like I said
I'm slowly kind of stepping down Walking
Dead videos to like one a week my next
one is actually gonna be that season 5
predictions video be sure to subscribe
below to get it I'll be posting that
later tonight
you can actually click here to watch it
right now I'll add the annotation as
soon as I post it and you can click here
to watch my review of the finale thanks
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives